mais ne vous pourrez vous prendre mais
simplement pouvez vous prendre
l'engagement ici devant les français que
parmi ces personnes les plus fortunées
qui ont fait des dons importants pour
vous ou pour votre campagne
il n'y a pas plusieurs cadres de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
plusieurs cadres de l'industrie chimique
et pétrolière plusieurs industries
banquet mais vous allez je vous demande
cela vous at on est ce que vous pouvez
me le dire selon suffisamment d'abord je
ne fais pas un contrôle d'identité nom
et l'identité transmise à la commission
nationale mais c'est juste est ce que
cet engagement on pouvait le mourre
entendez ça n'a aucun sens 1 la poule 1
un lit dans d'ajouter j'espère beaucoup
de sens mais je vais vous dire un
l'identité elle est protégée par la loi
elle est protégée par la loi mais bien
de la même soirée deux schémas kron vous
pouvez demain vous allez peut-être
couvert les là vous êtes en train d'être
de musique généreuse mais laissez moi je
vous fait vous dit triste mais je vous
dis juste que demain quand il s'agira
vis-à-vis des perturbateurs endocriniens
et prendre les décisions et pas
d'attendre qu'il y ait forcément un
substitut à quand il s'agira vis-à-vis
du diesel qui réunira de l'émission
culte chine qui font plus de cinquante
mille morts par an et bien il faudra
prendre les engagements et ne pas être
tenant lieu est bien parce que tout
financer votre campagne vais vous dire
je vais être totalement clair là quand
je prends l'engagement de notre tenue
par personne monsieur mans personne mais
donc vous apprenez on prend des langages
cher monsieur je prends l'engagement
réalisé solennel je me suis tenu par
essieu et donc je suis
le financement est transparent il est
soumis à une commission mais nous c'est
novateur soupçons 5
merci pardonnez moi mais pas bien qu'il
ya débat au ps oui
6 y était j'aurais été à la primaire si
j étais je ne serais pas là aujourd'hui
et si j étais je n'aurais pas mener les
combats que j'ai menés